AS WE JUMP TO OUR NEXT
GAME, FUTURE HASHTAG WARS.
>> TONIGHT IS ACTUALLY OUR 300TH
EPISODE OF @MIDNIGHT.
I POSED FOR THAT FOR LIKE FIVE
HOURS AND I THINK THEY WERE
A LITTLE CONSERVATIVE AROUND
THIS AREA BUT OTHERWISE I THINK
THEY DID A PRETTY GOOD JOB.
THIS MEANS WE BASICALLY HAD TO
COME UP WITH 300 DIFFERENT
HASHTAG WARS.
I GOTTA BE HONEST, WE THOUGHT
THE EVENT HORIZON OF US
RUNNING OUT OF THOSE WOULD HAVE
HAPPENED A YEAR AND A HALF AGO
BUT WE HAVEN'T DONE IT YET.
COMING UP WITH HASHTAGS IS NOT
EASY, AND IF YOU FORGOT THAT,
REMEMBER WE JUST DID
#BADTRAMPSTAMPS THIS EPISODE
ALONE.
SO COMEDIANS, YOU GUYS ARE OLD
PROS. WE COULD USE SOME HELP
CLEARLY, SO I WOULD LIKE YOU TO
COME UP WITH AS MANY
IDEAS FOR FUTURE HASHTAG WARS
THAT WE WILL USE AS YOU CAN.
I'M GONNA PUT 60 SECONDS ON THE
CLOCK AND BEGIN.
TOM LENNON.
>> #SIX WORDS IN THREE WORDS.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT.
POINTS.
RHYS DARBY.
>> #THANKSGIVING SEX MOVES.
>> Chris: POINTS.
THE STUFFING? POINTS.
>> JEN.
>> #RUIN A MAKE-A-WISH.
>> Chris: POINTS.
RHYS DARBY.
>> #WHY NO ONE LOVES ME.
>> Chris: POINTS. RHYS.
>> #INSIDE THE POPE'S CHAMBERS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
JEN KIRKMAN.
>> #MEL GIBSON'S BEST SLURS.
>> Chris: POINTS.
TOM.
>> #SMURF IN A MERKIN
>> Chris: POINTS.
TOM.
>> #RHYS D'ARBY'S MENU.
>> Chris: OH, POINTS.
JEN.
>> #TOM LENNON PARTY.
>> Chris: YES.
THAT'S THE END OF FUTURE HASHTAG
WARS.